누군가에게 다가가고 싶지만
선뜻 용기가 나지 않아 망설인 적이 있으신가요?
이번 5분 레벨업에서는
두 건의 참고서를 바탕으로
지뢰 겁먹어 망설이지 않고
용기 있게 일단 행동하는 방법
두 가지를 알려드릴게요
1. 치크킥
첫 번째, 자신과 거리 두기
여러분은 백덤블링을 할 수 있으신가요?
아마도 못 할 겁니다
왜냐하면 그냥 어려운 동작이니까요
하지만 누군가에게 다가간다는 건
정말 쉬운 동작인데도
왜 이리도 어려운 걸까요?
오, 오늘은 또 뭘 흘리신 거죠?
아, 커피를 마시다 좀 흘리는 바람에
오, 그렇구나 조심 좀 하시지
어, 그러면 내일 찾으러 오시면 돼요
아, 네 감사합니다
사람이기에 누군가에게 끌릴 수 있고
한 걸음 다가가고 싶은 마음이 생길 수 있습니다
하지만
그근데 혹시 번호가
네?
번호, 표 같은 건 원래 없었죠?
아, 네 알겠습니다 그럼 안녕히 있으세요
끌리는 상대에게 다가간다는 것은
생각보다 쉽지 않을 겁니다
왜요?
왜냐하면
용기가 없거든요
상처받을 용기가요
그래서 어떠한 행동조차 못하는 거죠
그런데 이런 순간에
곧바로 자신감을 회복하여
일단 행동할 용기를 얻는 방법이 있다는 사실을
알고 계신가요?
그 방법은 바로
자기 자신을 1인칭이 아닌
3인칭으로 지지하는 겁니다
실제로 밀시간대학의 에단크로스 교수팀은
한 가지 흥미로운 실험을 진행했는데요
우선 실험 참여자들에게 연설문을 발표하게 한 다음
A그룹에겐 주어를 나 라는 1인칭을 쓰도록 했고
B그룹에겐 자신의 이름을 3인칭 주어로 쓰도록 요청했습니다
그 결과 A그룹보다 B그룹이
전체적으로 훌륭하게 연설을 마쳤고
뜻으로도 불안감을 덜 느꼈다고 대답하였으며
뇌스캔기로 들여다본 결과도
훨씬 더 안정된 상태를 유지했습니다
즉, 자기 자신을 제3자로 여기는 화법을 사용하는 것만으로도
냉정을 찾는 데 필요한 심리적 거리를 얻을 수 있던 거죠
아, 근데요?
여기서 주의할 점은
자기 자신을 3인칭으로 부르는 화법은
그래, 왕대는 할 수 있다고
웬만하면 마음속으로만 하는 게 좋겠죠?
민망하잖아요
왜요, 오빠? 왜 이렇게 늦게 왔어?
두 번째, 완곡한 질문
호감 가는 상대와 가까워지고 싶지만
선뜻 다가가지 못하는 이유가 뭔지 아시나요?
바로 상대방이 불편해할까 봐 조심스럽기 때문인데요
요즘 이상한 사람이 너무 많은 것 같아요
그러게요
아, 그러고 보니 혜정 씨는 집이 어디예요?
편하게 대화를 하다 보면
다소 사적인 질문을 할 때도 있습니다
하지만
아, 집이요?
아직 덜 가까운 사이에서
너무 개인적인 정보를 말해야 하는 질문은 부담스러울 수 있습니다
그렇기 때문에
혜정 씨는 집이 어디 쪽이세요?
집이 어디예요?
보다는 집이 어디 쪽이세요?
와 같은 완곡한 질문을 하는 것이 좋습니다
왜냐하면
아, 저는 저기 호계사거리 쪽에 살아요
대충 애들로 대답할 수도 있고
아니면
그럼 시우 씨는 어디 쪽에 살아요?
저는 요 앞에 있는 팔단지
301동, 602 앞방과 여동생 방 사이에 낀 방에 살고 있죠
본인 판단하에 구체적으로 대답할 수도 있기 때문에
훨씬 더 편하고 덜 부담스럽거든요
아, 뭐예요?
개인 정보를 그렇게 막 알려줘도 되는 거예요?
아, 네 뭐 중국에 갖다 파셔도 돼요
됐거든요?
오, 근데 여동생 있으세요?
네, 뭐 있긴 한데
아, 근데 사람을 너무 귀찮게 해요
왜요?
아, 오빠 왜 이렇게 늦게 왔어
아니, 와준 게 어디냐?
지 오빠한테 이딴 작같이 생긴 키링셔틀이나 시키고
이거 진짜 에바 아니에요?
오, 수고비 두둑히 챙기지 않았나요?
혹시 미친놈이세요?
아, 그건 고맙게 생각하고 있죠
어, 뭐지?
우린 누군가에게 다가가기 위해
꽤 그럴듯한 명분을 만들곤 합니다
그 명분은 새로운 인연을 꽃피울 계기가 될 수 있습니다
하지만
왜, 뭔데?
아무리 좋은 명분을 가지고 있더라도
아, 아니야 아무것도
말하지 않으면, 표현하지 않으면
어떠한 드라마도
시작될 수 없습니다
그렇기에, 새드 엔딩의 주인공이 될지 모르더라도
아니, 왜 안 찾아가는 거야?
아, 죄송해요
연락처는 따로 드리기가 좀 힘들 것 같아요
한 번쯤은 표현해보는 게 어떨까요?
왜냐하면
아, 아, 네
그러면 오슨 내일 찾으러 올게요
뭐라도 결말이 있어야
새로운 드라마가 시작되죠
5분 안에 레벨업 비치 키를 구독하시고
실전 자기 개발 버프를 받아가세요